Robert Thomas the allstar wins the draw set
play bich Nick Ley out in front it carams
kyou shot down by dor broken up Kyu moves it
along kessle hinges in to the goal line out
in front off bunich and Seattle attempting
to survive it appears they will maybe Tatar
with the redirect Everly in the corner denied
Ice by Nick Ley toar to the slot dlan pounces
on it shoots it blocker save for Bennington
and now Ley off the glass sad can't get it
out good keep by dlan here's McAn with a shot
sealed off by Bennington what a great play by
in the skates of sunquist Oscar sunquist will
get to it reset by the blues Kel out in front
Sammy blade taken down by Adam Larson he's
on a three-game heater five assists in that
time period perunovich in the circle kyou he'll
dance a bit shoot it off the post no yes it stays
out now Tory Krug will start out 52 seconds
on the Manpower Advantage Shen seam pass they
score Oscar sunquist and a beautiful pass by
the captain Braden again 1221 left to go in
the opening period St Louis breaks the ice
watch the right part of your screen there's
Shen he gets some separation by Duman and
he throws the puck back and that space in
between Joey and Alexia and sunquist just has
a strong bottom hand and puts it into the back
of the net yeah again just playing with speed
and attacking off the rush it's a lot of times
you see a power play just want he'll Rim
it all the way around Jaden Schwarz almost
took the official out there Kevin Pollock
Larson walks the line Duman with a shot he
scores an answer from dumo Brian Duman 943 left
in Period one the Kraken tie it throwing it down
in behind he jumps back into the play watch
t of right there in a battle with Paro taking
away the eyes of Bennington that puck just
has eyes Finds Its way off he post past the
glove side of Bennington into the back of the
neck did you guys have to weigh in once a week
how did that work oh we would be every day in
my era no wonder now cyou turned aside by Joey
dord borgan out to Center we will now wenberg
out in front T of slams it off the pad of
Bennington what a beautiful pass there from
wber and here's the chance for Turbo what a
pass there what a beautiful pass there by
wiberg just throw it into an area let him
skate into it from our MC delivery super Mo and
the left pad saved by Bennington and a beauty K
shot denied going for 12 by dord here come the
Kraken a man up Everly wenberg mccan wenberg in
front they score that's hockey baby Oliver Bor
strand no mistake power play stri Seattle by
one the save the odd man break and look at his
passing play Everly to wiberg to McAn the wiberg
and then Oliver borkshire and the whole key to
this play he does not stop the puck and shoot
it he shoots it off the pass right into the back
of the net and Alex wber has made two brilliant
passes Brandon sad Pittsburgh native almost gave
it away to bork strand brunovich pickpocketed by
bork strand he's got tolven in another pass what
a play Ellie Tolan sent up by yni Gard outstanding
Tick T goal 3 to one Seattle it doesn't get any
better than this when you talk about retrieval
knows over the puck mentality and letting the puck
do the work look at his passing play a two on0 in
front of the net after the steal by Oliver Bor
strand he gets his Puck to Tolen it back to gour
and Ellie buries it into the back of the net and
the Kraken with two quick ones have a two- goal
lead perunovic picked up up top by mccan top of
the Ring neighbors to the goal line bvic and now
perunovic with a shot tipped in a high tip Robert
Thomas cruising through the slot it's a power play
goal right at the end of the power play we'll see
then it Lees gives his teammates an opportunity
to track it down and get it down but once he
went up the middle there on the fan all of a
sudden St Louis got a second chance JT and give
Thomas credit that's a beautiful redirect off
the shot Brian dlan 355 left through the middle
to the outside barovsky Schwarz off the side of
the goal what a chance right here for Seattle's
17 Jaden Schwarz what a period by 22 here look
at this he's a man unbelievable beautiful
look out off Bennington with a chance for
gourd he's been over it and the
nose over the puck mentality and
like the way when he plays like that
Thomas bnic scores pav bnic with a
dart 1833 left to go in the third period we're
tied they Chi through the neutral zone just
putting the puck into a place where you can go get
it a battle here with alexc and right here CW to
Thomas Thomas finds bavage in this soft spot right
in the top of the circle he's able to beat Joey
dord but all it was was chipping dump and go get
the puck win a battle and you find with naav all
alone and the crack it he got five guys back
and bunevich just find just like M couple of
yards and it's exactly what happened here
they come again led by Thomas right through
the middle Paro stopped by dord as pero had a
clear route to the net where just St Louis is
knifing through boy oh boy they're lucky didn't
get a penalty there is that duner that comes in
here and hooks around just right around the
waist area and Paro he talked about how great
of his season had he had lenberg went down the
crowd moans about it we'll play on here 735 left
to steal Kier wiberg stopped by Bennington done
good play on kyou here come the Kraken Yanni gour
gains The Zone delay shoots it shoulder down
it's loose cleaned up bich and back out look
at the golender he's down he's down and Yanni
tries to get it up top and the puck ends up
hitting Bennington right off the side of the
Mask pops the snap referee blows a whistle 3
three Dunn will keep the Zone move
it dun with a shot off Bennington
he'll freeze it good save there that
was a good save good idea there by
Vince St and Bennington wasn't going
to take any chance to trying to move
this Puck comes right back towards him
and he was able to absorb it and freeze
it Seattle back out Schultz takes a peak
Here Comes Tatar he's in a shot kicked out
by Bennington 237 left B nvic rall in good
stick to court off the side of the goal Shin
to the outside and back bich reorganizing for
St Louis Shen bich scores pav bnic wins it in
overtime and then move the puck Move
Yourself shanon bunevich give and go
and the blues with the overtime
winner after being down two do